even though the Cowboys got mouth [__]
yeah you
guys I'm thinking about switching teams
no way wow I got to dude I can't keep
doing this to myself it's I'm not even
saying this to you got to ride it out
you got ride we've been Nicks fans our
whole life they had one [__] did the
same y'all got yeah but y'all got Rings
[__] 28 years ago
boohoo we don't got nothing we've never
seen victory in our life we're not going
to stop being Nick's fans yeah but
that's you're spoiled that's what it is
I was spoiled I was spoiled early on but
it's also like that's part of being a
New York you have to be a Nicks fan it
is not inherent to being a Dallas person
it's America's team I don't know about
that it's America's team that has more
clout than even a mix no cuz there's not
a lot of people who are just like I'm so
proud to be from Dallas and if you don't
R for the Cowboys how could you possibly
be it's so stupid this is propaganda you
guys have bought into and it's so dumb
hold on hold y'all the loudest
[__] bro louder than nickv
Dallas people are not Cowboys fans no
they are Cowboys fans but but it's not
like if you're not a Cowboys fan how
[__] could you how [__] could you
what is it like oh you're not a Cowboys
fan that's a little
weird okay I don't believe that if
you're not you don't even have to like
basketball you have to be a Knicks fan
you be Alex I'm not even saying it's to
take a shot of you you don't really keep
up with the NBA but you have to be a
Knicks fan there's no way you cannot be
that's my point if you're not a football
fan you're not a Cowboy fan in Dallas if
you are uh there's people that didn't
root for the Cowboys but it's not like I
don't care if you watch football or not
you have to be a cowboy okay so what
you're saying is the Dallas Cowboys are
not part of the identity of someone who
is from Dallas whereas the New York
Knicks are part of the identity of a New
Yorker you cannot be a New Yorker
without being a Knicks fan and I mean
that in terms of the people that move
here and they're like hey I've been here
for 10 years so now I'm a New Yorker not
until you're a Knicks fan you have to
pledge allegiance to the New York Knicks
and suffer with us if you get to keep
your team that wins championships and
then call yourself a New Yorker it's not
fair that's not fair that should be a
part of immigration if you immigrate
here you got to buy a ticket nose bleeds
you can go to a next game can I can I
tell you what I did when my mom got her
citizenship fans I tested her on the
Knicks did you really I did what' you
ask her I say uh what are the chances
you'll get butt [__] first 100% the
dad or the
Knicks and she got it right she got it
right she got it right the Knicks are
going to break your
[__]
night no but the transplants they could
be Brooklyn Fans because they're equally
as shitty but we never are going to
consider you a New Yorker so it's like
you can have that team I'll be honest I
don't consider New Yorkers that are
Brooklyn Nets fans New Yorkers no like
if you're born and raised here and
you're a Brooklyn Nets fan to me what if
you're from Brooklyn you're from
Connecticut what if you're you're conut
you're from Connecticut if you if you
identify as a New Yorker but you are a
fan of the Brooklyn Nets you're from
Connecticut and I kind of feel that wow
I'm being honest if Jay-Z stayed part
owner for a little bit longer I might
have switched but the fact that he even
gave
he was like [__] these [__] I'm
done I'm a Nick if Doan would have sold
Jay-Z a piece of the Knicks he's in he's
not even looking at the net that's true
100% right 100% right no no if you are a
fan of the Brooklyn Nets you have to
revoke your New York citizenship and
that's my point about y'all you have to
be Nicks fans because you're proud of
being New Yorkers but you're saying this
doesn't exist in Dallas no dude if the
vast majority of people in Dallas who
watch football are Cowboys fans but if
you don't watch football you don't care
about the Cowboys you guys and I'm not
doesn't watch football akos a lot of
people don't watch football come on son
that's the biggest sport in all they
have high school football games they
play It's the biggest sport by far it's
the biggest sport but what I'm saying is
and again I'm not I'm using you as
example I'm not trying to [__] on you I
don't give a [__] about basketball he's
a Knicks fan a little bit I care a
little bit who's who are the best you
kind of care but you're not like you're
a Knicks fan like
come I'm not Mark bro he could have went
with Mark but he went with you mark well
Mark's not a New Yorker if Mark Mark was
in New York born and raised he'd be a
ncks fan never would watch a game I'm a
die hard magic fan dude I'm a die hard
Orlando Magic fan don't ask me anything
about I'm G be honest with you bro I'm
gonna switch teams well who no no no I I
know I know you're going to do that uh
you you're
sick I thought you're calling me
ill no no no what I'm trying to say is I
I don't know if I believe you when it
comes to being a from Dallas and not
being a cowbo I I just can't I don't see
that I don't I knew plenty of kids
growing up who weren't Cowboys fans what
were they Gerald was like a San
Francisco 49ers fan yeah he's [__]
Chinese yeah that does make a little I
think just just the Mexicans and any
other raced non-white probably weren't D
Mexicans love the Cowboys love the
Cowboys that's fact culturally they see
themselves as Cowboys they just try not
to get kicked out dude in Mexico City
smart that's part that's
smart to that when you
travel travel abroad pay attention to
that adopt the culture if the culture is
heterosexuality that's what you are for
that week okay yeah yeah they like
dressing up like why not just dress up
heterosexual you know what I mean like
just just put it on like drag that's the
costume you're draged drag straight for
a week you know I mean no brainer any go
on so are you like a free agent fan
right now you so who you going to go
with Chiefs are an option dude they're
oh you're come on bro you can't do
that fan be a Jags fan do that you got
to pick a bad team no I'm not picking
you can't pick the best teaming a bulls
fan when Jordan was after he won you
said he was yeah yeah you know a lot of
people were Bulls fans when Jordan was
there and they're not Bulls fans anymore
do you respect them sure who cares if I
respect them they're happy what they
give a [__] about my respect they're
happy they're happy dude they it doesn't
mean nothing they probably happened they
had the black and red they got to get
Fly and [__] like that I mean the
outfits were
CRA like no they were killing were you a
little bit of a of a bulls fan in that
in that time I was a bulls hater I was a
[__] who was like yo Jordan
ain't better than bird I was a [__]
Jordan hater son I ain't going to lie I
was I was the most I was the loudest
Jord be honest you I was the loudest
Jordan hater ever bro I said Magic
Johnson was better than than Michael
Jordan I ain't seen Magic Johnson play
once first time I saw Max Johnson was
when he had eight and I still was like
yo n he whoop I was a Jordan hater too
and that was stupid but why were you a
Jordan hater and it got nothing to do
with you I just decided my brother
didn't like him so I was like yeah I
guess [__] that guy son that's the
dumbest [__] I ever heard I have a
reason to be a Jordan hater he's giving
me pain yeah destroying Us in the
playoffs yeah I just wanted to see
someone else win so I remember when he
came back I did the I I was a Jordan
celebrator I was like no I just got to
appreciate greatness this [__]
going [__] around and almost loseing
game seven to the Pacers I'm like he
would he would the second I start
rooting for him push it to seven [__]
games with the Indiana Pacers piece of
[__] the team the team we hate the other
team the other team oh that's actually
what made me an NBA fan is Reggie Miller
eight points in 8 seconds shout out that
was unbelievable shout out to [__] but
you can't be a Chiefs fan you got to be
a from Dallas how are you going to be a
front runner bro it's cuz it's the
logically the smartest thing in the
world to do oh so gay you're so [__]
gay you suck
dick you [__] you can't go to Jamaica
you [__] gay
IO being a front running dude they're
Geniuses they're the ones that they're
always happy oh God damn you're so gay
yeah this is disgusting like it really
is disgusting I'm so happy y'all don't
even really watch book you
[__] I can't believe that you are going
to be a women chose Team Real
Talk he's so cute I like Tay Swift team
it's like step is team Taylor S yo I'm
team Taylor I'm team Taylor let's go you
got one thing right yeah Taylor's
[__] amazing but I didn't wait until
she was the biggest artist in the world
to like her
yes what you say I
[Music]
did you say that I wait you might be
hypoc literally her last show in America
are
you disgusted bro literally the last you
don't even watch sports you don't get to
judge me dude aash no you're too real
for this you actually care about
football you know the game you love the
game I'm done and the Cowboys are never
going to be good unless Jerry Jones dies
and he's not going to die anytime soon
so this is what it is
RA the Cowboys win this win the Super
bowl next year I'll come back I'll come
back separation why are there no rules
for this no there's not what do you want
chaos that's what I realized there's no
rules camons are the funniest thing he
was like yo Jerry Jones you got to bring
the coke back in the locker room that
[__] was working back in
he's absolutely right '90s he's
absolutely right 9s mhm yes do whatever
it takes dude but you can't switch come
on no but but can you at least
acknowledge what you're talking about it
has a little hint of [__] ass it yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I'd be much happier
big hint of it would you yes cuz you're
not really a fan you don't really know
the culture of the team you haven't
really bled for the team you haven't
rooted for that team for decades and
then it hasn't been a cold night and
Arrowhead you know what is all that
about who cares that is sports come on
dude if you always just go for the team
that's about to win it's it's nothing I
can't just like the player root for the
player so that's you can like the player
but you're te you could have a team but
then you could have a favorite player
that's you could do that but have
another team yes yeah I don't care about
the Chiefs outside of momes okay just
like the player but suffer through this
the losses and the adversity like the
rest of us because the victory feels so
sweet when let me tell you something the
Cowboys will never win the Knicks will
never win don't you bug n you you L
y'all got some chance because you're at
least on an upward trajectory cuz you
took Jaylen Brunson from the Mavericks
which also [__] crushed me and you
won the Chris STS trade which also
[__] crushed me I'm sticking with the
Mavs Cuban at least is not going to let
his ego get in the way every single time
so I'm like okay fine but then
supporting Jerry Jones it's like why
you're never going to hire a GM you're
always going to ruin everything why
would I just keep watching this for
what if he dies I'll come back
because that's why because that's life
dude I got to give Doan give Dolan
credit he stepped back and the team
looks promising they got guys running it
who know what they're doing I would
still be a Knicks fan I'd still give it
a few more years Cowboys I'm out I think
I'm out dude we need some more Boston
working class energy in here D when I
saw Boston had the most spoiled [__]
Sports run in history I was in Aruba I'm
pretty sure and I saw
place the Cleveland Cavaliers with
LeBron win in NBA championship sitting
next to two people from akan Ohio wow
when I saw the reaction yeah from this
guy yeah and his wife I mean I think he
literally teared up rightly so yeah but
the excitement the Jo I mean I'm excited
watching but him I'm like oh wow it's
going to be so sweet when the Knicks
finally win a championship like I that
day just being out in the streets
hugging every single person that's
wearing a [__] Nick's Jersey even if
they're not walking up to the guy
selling of [__] hot dogs we [__]
did it we did every single person that's
been through decades punch people light
a couch on fire loot the stor come on AR
we will light Barclays on fire we will
walk across the bridge which which with
tiki torches and we will light parlays
on fire Philly was bad we're going to
start eating rats and [__] CRA bro don't
you want to be part of that no come on
not at all that sounded awful are you
going to be that sounded I'm back to
reading books you might read you might
be a big time [__] reader bro are you
going to be an Australia cricket fan no
no why not cuz Indian is part of my
identity that's a part of my DNA
genetically a part of Australia austr
that's genetically a part of me you
should be in Australia at least India
makes it to the final the Cowboys
haven't even been to a conference
Championship yo you should be in
Australia y'all have been to the finals
once in your lifetime in my lifetime
yeah the Cowboys have not been I think
we all just got a football team dude I'm
a Cowboys fan hey have fun I'm a die
hard cowo I want you I want you to do
this and I want you to invest and see
what it feels like now see I'm a Cowboys
fan I want you to see it as long as
you're not I will be okay if they win we
can't ever let AAR celebrate okay good
Lu you make this decision right now yeah
yeah yeah if you make this decision
right now and Dallas wins it means
nothing to you and you know it no I
don't you pretend to be excited but it
won't be there because you abandoned
your team oh I abandoned my don't act
like what a [__] I am is this over
what an [__] I am you're better than
Sports is that the you is that the guy
you are you're the I'm better than
sports sports are dumb no but you
character you're playing right now AB a
bunch of adults just running into each
other with helmets well so cor why you
guys like this I love sports no you want
the Joy from sports but you don't want
to put in the effort you want to do your
part as a fan what effort have you done
exactly that's the effort that's the
effort you do that's effort is
the effort is the effort is a despair
out you got championships and you're
still it's not enough you're a void
you're an empty oh you're a bottomless
pit how many Nicks games you been to
season ticket holder no this year season
ticket holder um
zero don't talk to me about investing
emotion don't you dare cuz you don't
even go to the game how many Cowboys
games have you gone to I've been to one
in the past no this year I have not been
any cuz I don't live in Dallas if I
lived in Dallas
you go to Philadelphia to see your girl
family all the time why don't you go see
them when they play the Eagles come
that's [__] I'm afraid for my S the
Eagles yeah yeah I you won't do it you
won't do it no no I will not go to an
Eagles game as a cowb scared yeah AB
scary n let me tell you something if the
Knicks are playing Philadelphia do you
think that we're going
incognito hell no you're not going it's
far it's kind of far it's far and they
play here they play right here you got
to wear a Chief's Jersey the next next
pod you got to go full Chief's uniform
Mahomes Jersey I would do that I cannot
believe that you're doing this but what
I don't like is the pretention that you
have with why is it pretention why is it
pretention like what the [__] is that
like the fact that you're like oh what
are we so silly like you are so silly to
root for the same team like like you're
above like you're better than people
who've been rooting for the same team
their whole life why would you do this
you're so stupid to do the thing you're
supposed to do in sports yes we're all
submitting to it this is what happens
with sports you're doing the stupid
thing no I'm jumping on the bandwagon is
the super thing so fun dude so good dud
you don't feel it you actually don't I
really do I really do what will the boys
from the tickets condom option condom
sex for the rest of your life you're
going to not you're going to come you're
going to come but it's not going to be
the same you're not going to feel the
walls caving in it's not a facial you're
not going to feel that wet you're never
going to feel wet from Patrick moles
Patrick Mahomes will never make you feel
wet Cowboys been giving me dry dick for
28 years and you know what one day
they're going to spit on it and it's
going to feel incredible they going to
spit on that little tur cutter and slice
it right open and you're going to
[__] love it if you stay on I'm not
saying also the chiefs were way worse
long no I'm
joking go the chiefs were way worse way
longer no they weren't W when's the last
Super Bowl like the 6 they didn't go to
the Super they went to conference
championships again they would get there
they'd be the best team in the league
they were good oh God they were
good miles yeah what the [__] are you
talking about you want your team to just
go to conference championships no but
you can't say they were so bad for so
long they were way worse when did they
win a Super Bowl like 65 or something 63
yeah yeah again I didn't I wasn't a fan
Super Bowls won the I always had kind of
a soft spot and this is where it also
lines up a little bit still a stretch
they're sort of Rivals it's crazy why
are they because they the chiefs were in
Dallas first right they have a Dallas
tie yeah so this is your [__]
another one that's [__] excuse the
coach of the Lions oh God Dallas
Cowboy [__] great friend of the
ticket was always on once a week
fantastic Dan Campbell that's another
team that would be fun to root for and
the LI are historically they've never
been they're historically bad but he's
great you're not committing you're also
joining the Lions when they finally show
a little bit of life and lions fans
probably don't want you if I did this if
I did this hold on hold on if I did this
if like the Nets were going to go to the
finals and look like they were going to
win and I jumped on the bandwagon you
would never let me have the end of it
you would call me the biggest
[__] flame-throwing idiot stupid
head [__] every single
time tell something I would support you
I would I would support you whatever
makes you happy dude at the end of the
day I just want my friend to be happy
that's all I want yo therapy sucks don't
ever go to therapy yo this is what
happens I'm canceling mine this week
[__] this yeah don't go to
therapy miles who's your team you don't
even watch football I do watch football
this's the hard part growing up I picked
the r wor when you do it's worse if do
watch football yeah enough sure this
guy's just talking he don't watch
nothing it's worse that you do watch
football and you're still willing to
bandwagon if you didn't watch all the
buck grown up what happened they were
good in 2002 and then what happened why
did you stop rooting for them I just
stopped watching football in general
like I slowed my whole thing but you
love football and you can't change in
the middle it's worse what you're doing
is worse you love the game you much
smarter it's much smarter why is it
smarter because lose the respect of
every man you've ever met in your life
instantaneously if you tell men hey I'm
a bandwagon fan if that's your identity
hey which team do you like whatever is
best I just like to feel the victory
yeah you will immediately lose respect
from every male that you ever meet what
the equal don't respect that [__] either
what's the equivalent in standup cuz he
needs to understand this so like figure
out what the equivalent would be in
standup so you get it because this is
disgusting what uh like a new style of
standup comes out like let's say like um
uh uh puppets are really popular and
then you just start oh I like could do
puppets it's not the same yeah it's
really not the same I'll be honest I
tried to get there but it's not but uh
but let's think of something else
um if you wanted to be a Giants fan
there's nothing like
sports there's British
soccer even even if the Eagles were
actually good I would never root for
Giants oh we don't believe you start
them too much you like the Giants
because that's popping right now if you
just started to do woke comedy because
it's popping yeah but a comic is who I
am a Cowboys fan is not it's a part of
separated the team from his identity
which is [__] that's to you don't
care about everybody that you meet
losing respect for you like is that not
like is like a part of you I don't think
that happens it is it is now my Luther
my best friend big Dynasty guy it's so
funny it's the funniest thing in the
world it's so funny for him to just be a
Lakers fan and then be a Warriors fan
and then maybe come back to the L It's
the funniest thing to watch I love it
guys you get annoyed at first and then
you're like you know what this guy's got
to figured out this just sounds like a
bad guy yeah and I
love kindest he's a fantastic Guy this
is a character flaw yeah this is what
Gandhi was talking about when he's like
I love your Jesus I don't like your
Christians Luther perfect example this
is a character flaw we have to get to
the bottom of this we have to get to
really good because Luther is very
Christ he's incredible Christian he's
really this is the one unchristian thing
about him it it's really a he guy's
happy all the time dude H what if you
just like a you think that's the reason
you're
miserable the no it adds it adds a lot
of misery it adds a lot of misery you
don't even know dude you might sleep
better hon yeah I would I would sleep
better for a fact have you ever talked
about the Cowboys in therapy be honest
no that's that's part the problem Jes
Christ you got to bring that up I'm not
that crazy you got bring it let's just
work out like you're at a bar ready yeah
and we're hanging out watching what's
your team bro
I'm I'm a Chief's guy dude yeah oh they
F must be nice being a Chief's guy yeah
you got the best quarterback maybe in
history I mean this guy's incredible
they've been on a run yeah he's the
reason I'm a Chiefs fan if you get down
to it man what do you what do you mean
he's the reason you want a chief fan
before him no no no they were I kind of
liked him but not like that much I
didn't care that much what were you
before I was a Cowboy fan and every
football fan right there would be like
oh I get it right there be like oh yeah
fair enough fair enough so wait a minute
you just sto being a fan of the cow boys
and then started becoming Fant cuz they
were the best team in yeah eventually I
finally just realized that until Jerry
Jones dies they're just never going to
actually be good and he's not dying
anytime soon and his son also seems like
kind of a [__] idiot to be honest
with you so I just don't I think this is
when you stand up and find a new seat at
the B I'm like I'm going to talk to
somebody else what are you drinking at
this bar dude everybody is miserable
with their team he's going to go to
another I'm not going to tolerate this
from if you guys were football fans I
would we're Nick fans we don't want to
hear anything else about it yeah but you
can't again you can't be a New Yorker
and not next you're a spoiled brat when
it comes to sports you had an absolute
Dynasty 28 years I've invested thousands
one Championship what I would do for One
Singular championship